tous deux se retrouvent sur 100 ce parc
de alias de fracture est bonne aulas en
france elle annales du des stars des
saisies c'est drôle il sort le 6
décembre et aujourd'hui je suis hyper
content pour deux choses c'est qu'on
peut déjà commencer à y jouer et surtout
va pouvoir tester le nodule us rives
c'est locustes rives du nez ça va nous
permettre de sentir les odeurs qu'il ya
autour de nous dans le jeu et aurait
remercié moi j'ai pris beaucoup de
risques en pénétrant secrètement les
locaux d'ubisoft ou alors ils l'ont
philips que cette vidéo est sponsorisé
peut réussir je sais pas j'enfile la
bête j'ai jamais testé cette chose on va
découvrir ça ensemble
donc tu vois des gens qui l'ont utilisée
avant moi parce que ça sente le beau oui
nous sommes de retour dans la villa
familiale alors qu'ici vos faire au
caire et dans le salon maman maman ou
titulaire tout comme d'accord donc
hartmann est enfermé dans le sous sol
doit faire une réunion de boxe comme
d'hab il nous faut un côté ça va juste
essayer un petit choc ue c'est pas dit
qu'on va devoir les fouiller la chambre
de notre ami cartman ok c'est celle là
les amis annoncé chiante mec attend est
ce qu'on peut non non non il ne serait
pas ils osaient non même si ça me lâcher
bonheur de pgp ad hoc
j'ai prévu un son totalement dégueulasse
au cas où un mec [ __ ] alors lâchant du
coup c'est quoi c'est ça sa chambre
c'est pas ça c'est ça oui ces agents de
cartman au mondial c'est philippe
mondiale sinon allez croiser on est
foutu un cahier celador sur son journal
intime
oh mon dieu le journal intime de cartman
keskili marque à votre avis est-ce que
c'est étonnant non j'arrête bee ware do
not open coonelly away
quel code fuck you mom cartman je le
descends te montrer ce que c'est le
respect envers les parents m'ont bien
fait rire
ok c'est parti j'arrive et sa monnaie
n'est stern au moins six kilos n'est pas
activé you may cry place si oui comment
le bateau as tu peux créer un hub
régional cadets let's go cube est ok
alors vous allez vous parler aux bosses
parle moi aussi j'ai une couronne et une
cape d'où tu crois que suis pas super
héros qu'est ce que c'est que ça
[ __ ] je suis battu dans le premier
j'étais fort il a peut-être à la radio
koi djemba djemba et porter le défoncer
ce parti comme mon dieu c'est la goutte
d'eau qui va les tuer cela dit personne
chier dans mes 3 nov
pitt aussi mme piloquet numérique qui
opère une stomie au bénin je la prenne
au sérieux tels fabio main incroyable
histoire
fatima je suis ému qu'est-ce que non
la pulsion xxi fait un vieux québec
non non je ne rappelais non tu sens
clément les jo touristes ont tellement
ça envoie du gaz
ok on va sauver la galaxie aux côtés de
iron man et de ce match à moi tu es
chaud alors on y va quand je me rase du
gouffre pression gérant le jeu peut en
mourir si l'on respire trouve sa puce
vous jure on a embaumé tout le studio du
condé sur noireau vers la boxe au j'ai
eu un point et un casque splendide sa
mission accomplie au nom au nom des gens
l'impression d'avoir pu mettre mon nez
dans une red eu assez bref vient pas
juste lui tendre une corde c'est d'avoir
à faire 600 p mais qu'est-ce qui peut
être pire qua non
non nos eaux
je sais c'est pas d'épée d'humains monga
cdp d'une autre race bien plus grâce que
les humains à petit feu
x craft une taxe est malade alors là
j'avais dû faire ça avatar stp auquel
cas sa défaite s'occuper de chimie 3 mai
3 ça va chier bon gars mon gars je vais
je vais la rentrée dans direct je met un
coup de poing direct je mette la bim
assez nul 40 prend des gars il ya moins
de wisches partie d'un igloo wade est
clair suis jaloux d'hommes qui bouclait
petit bouclier
j'ai bien fait moins quatre cas il sort
lui qui est parti au monde doit faire
quoi
des doigts mais geof pour les doigts
rage pendant la majeure souvent en
bataille et voitures qui passaient
s'arrêtent tous drogba petit laser dans
ta gueule de punch beach hockey ça va
chier je m'emploie spéciale je sais pas
ce qu'il fait écho la spéciale mais on a
tendance à faire trop mal c'est parti
allez c'est fini
iomega sûr on est là au costume ridicule
au nom du hockey chez l'harmattan thémis
et enfance à son bâton soir
oui ben voilà jusqu'à fin de ce diabète
ou mauvaises odeurs est mort dans la cij
afin de cette petite démo [ __ ] on a
tellement envie de faire tout le jeu
tout de suite voici dans ce que je fais
c'est demeuré afrique dans les entrepôts
de vie sauf que je vole une copie du jeu
c'est une blague 1 800 appelé par la
police croyez-moi ce truc envoie une
odeur mais demeure bas à tel point que
j'ai ça j'ai ça à côté quand même un
beau nizon tonique c'est pas mal c'est
ce à quoi je suis déçu ne puissiez pas
sentir l'odeur puisque dans le cul si
vous voyez ce que je vois mais là vous
pouvez pas sentir ce que je sens
malheureusement cette sortie juste pour
pour la promo du jeu donc on pourra
jamais en trouvant un commerce mais
c'est vraiment incroyable c'est une
vraie innovation je pense que c'est
l'avenir clairement sortir du prout
quand tu joues c'est le futur le futur
et l'arbre parce que moi j'ai mal aux
futures us cela il fallait non plus mais
ça me regarde et en soirée une prochaine
vidéo et on se retrouvera le 6 décembre
pour faire un petit let's play sur soc
parle de fracture et de bottes paul
hatry d'un projet nos portes ou bien
vers cela vous regarde et je retourne
sentir des putschs à tout le monde
pousse un hameçon c'est que ça sans même
qu enfin ça traîne là l'odeur quoi